- What's up everybody?
I'm back with Maya Rudolph.
Give it up!
(audience claps and cheers)
We've done a lot of Skyping
and Zooming in the last year.
Mm-hmm.
It's led to more than
a few technical issues
to say the least.
For example, this happened last summer
when I was talking with
"Bones" and "SEAL Team" actor,
David Boreanaz.
- I can't hear you.
But I wish I could read lips, but I can't.
I'll put Louis down.
- Okay.
Navy
SEAL.
Navy.
- Okay, this is like a game.
Sounds like shirt, okay?
- You play, you play.
- Yes!
SEAL Team.
- Yes! SEAL Team.
- I did like half the interview like that.
Now in honor of Maya lending her voice
to the animated film, "Luca,"
we're going to take away
her voice for another round
of the David Boreanaz, Can't Hear Me Game.
♪ The David Boreanaz Can't Hear Me Game ♪
(audience applauds)
Get it, Jessie.
Do you like a good game night, Maya?
- I love it.
Bring it on Kelly.
- I do, too.
Hey, well, we're not competing this time.
We're together.
But man, next time we
will go against each other
'cause I sense the competitive energy
and I'm really into it.
- No, no.
I always lose.
- Oh, you know what?
Apparently on this show, I do as well.
Like I don't know what's happening.
A good game night at someone's
house, I am the hero.
But not here.
Well, this is a virtual version
of the classic 19th
century game, Charades.
Maya and I will take turns
trying to get the other
to say a word or phrase.
The catch is, we will be on mute.
So we can't hear each other.
Since we're on mute,
we're allowed to say the words,
use motions and use props.
If we want to pass, we
hold up our pass card.
If we can get a total of six
words correct in two rounds,
everyone in our house
seats will win a prize.
So let's not fail them, Maya.
(audience claps and cheers)
All right, let's do it.
Mute my mic and I'll go first.
Okay, let's get 60 seconds on the clock.
We ready?
I'm so ready.
Okay.
And go!
- Okay.
Oh, are we starting?
Oh, you're a dog.
You're a dog.
You're a puppy.
You're a pet.
Two words.
Second word. Second word.
Bark.
- Nope.
- Second word.
Dog.
Hot.
Hot dog.
- Yes.
(bell dings)
Okay.
- Hair?
Brown, blonde.
Blonde?
- Blonde hair, she said it.
- Blonde.
- She said it.
(bell dings)
- Dumb blonde, blonde.
- Oh, oh, oh.
- Hey, who are you?
I'm yelling at you.
Why am I yelling?
- I can't do this.
I can't do this.
- 'cause I took my shoe off.
- Pass
- Okay. Here we go.
- I'm sitting down.
Where's my shoe.
Oh no, I fell down.
I fell down.
Oh no, I'm rolling.
Rolling Stones. (laughs)
Break.
Oh, rock and roll.
Rock and roll.
- No.
- Rock and Roll?
Break, oh.
Kelly Clarkson.
Hey, American...
What's happening?
(Kelly laughs)
Singing? Performing? Rockstar?
(buzzer buzzes)
(beep)
- Oh my God
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm just curious.
- Break dancing.
- Oh my god
You said break dancing?
I was like Rolling Stones.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God.
So, we basically-
- I let you down
and I feel guilty.
- No, here's the thing.
I just got on the ground for you, man.
I did break dancing.
- I don't have enough space.
What am I gonna do?
I better get this right with my face.
- We're gonna have those
bloopers for the rest of time.
Okay. (laughs)
Okay, okay.
So we need four right to win a prize
for everyone in our house seats.
I feel fine.
I feel confident.
- We got this.
- I feel confident.
So Maya is giving clues this time.
Mute her mic and 60
seconds on the clock, so.
- I can mouth the word, right?
- Go!
Yes, you can use your mouth.
Go.
Stirring, eating, eating.
- Spaghetti.
- Sushi.
Eating.
You're eating something?
Soup?
Your, spaghetti!
(bell dings)
Noodles?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Flipping a pancake.
Flipping a pizza.
Pizza.
A round pizza.
Frying pan.
(bell dings)
You can say it.
Okay.
Two words.
Second word.
Rain.
First word.
Purple rain! Purple rain!
(bell dings)
Fourth one.
Okay.
Second word.
I can't see that.
I can't. Pillow? Stripe?
Stripe. White stripes.
(buzzer buzzes)
- Pillow.
- It was pillow?
I said pillow.
I said pillow!
- She said pillow?
- Okay. (screams happily)
(audience claps)
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna break dance for you. (laughs)
She said, "Kelly Clarkson."
Girl, I was like, my mom is gonna see that
and be like, girl, you need to
stop dancing on TV. (laughs)
We did it.
(horn honking)
- That was the sexiest
break dancing I've ever seen.
- It was intense.
It was amazing.
So good, in fact, you
couldn't name it. (laughs)
Everyone in our house
seats is a winner y'all.
In honor of Maya's movie, "Luca,"
which is set on the Italian Riviera,
you're all getting an Emeril Lagasse
Pasta & Beyond pasta maker.
You're welcome.
(audience claps and cheers)
Enjoy fresh homemade pasta
at home in just minutes.
Plus, it doubles as a juicer
and frozen dessert maker.
Damn, so you can make
sorbet, frozen yogurt,
and even gelato.
A whole Italian meal this thing makes.
Okay.
Thank you so much for playing, Maya.
I can't wait to break dance
for you in person one day.
- I know.
Let's do in person, please.
I'll break dance for you.
- Okay
- Thank you, Kelly.
- Everyone, be sure to
check out Maya in "Luca."
It's on Disney Plus starting tomorrow.